JUST WON $10
ON THIS SCRATCH-OFF, HOMIE.
- PSSH, MAN,
QUIT PULLING MY DICK.
- WHAT?
- COME UP IN HERE LYING TO ME.
I AIN'T BUYING IT.
YOU PULLING MY DICK.
- FIRST OF ALL,
I AIN'T LYING TO YOU,
AND, SECOND OF ALL,
THAT'S NOT THE PHRASE.
- COME UP IN HERE, PISS ON MY
DICK, TELL ME IT'S RAINING.
- PISS ON MY LEG,
AND TELL ME IT'S RAINING.
- OH, I SEE, NOW YOU GONNA PISS
AND PULL ON MY DICK?
COME ON.
- DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT YOU GOT
ALL YOUR [bleep] WRONG?
- NO, ACTUALLY,
YOU GOT IT WRONG.
YEAH.
- I--
- YEAH, SEE?
YOU AIN'T EVEN GOT A DICK
TO STAND ON.
- OKAY.
OKAY, LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
WHAT DO YOU CALL THOSE LITTLE
PLASTIC BUILDING BLOCKS?
- WHAT YOU MEAN,
DICKOS?
- NAME A FAMOUS COMIC STRIP
DETECTIVE.
- LEG TRACY.
WHAT'S WITH THE QUESTIONS, MAN?
- DO YOU KNOW THE NAME
OF A GIANT CARTOON ROOSTER?
- FOGHORN DICKHORN.
- OKAY, YOU DONE.
YOU DONE.
GIVE ME THAT.
- ALL RIGHT.
YO, YOU JUST GOTTA--
YOU GOTTA LEAVE NOW, HUH?
JUST 'CAUSE I GOT
A DICK UP ON YOU?
I'M A-LEG-TED TO MARIJUANA.